but first rule and ruin that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
New York prosecutors trying to take down
Trump before 2024 duh you know this
apparent moved toward indicting the
former president it's as predictable as
a Biden stumble climbing the stairs of
Air Force One
now rather than focusing on putting away
violent criminals
D.A Alvin Bragg wants to make a name for
himself by squaring off with Donald
Trump on a case that is as pathetic as
it is political
Bragg made a future Trump prosecution
the Cornerstone of his campaign for D.A
I'm the candy in the race who has the
experience with with Donald Trump I was
the chief Deputy in the Attorney
General's office we sued the Trump
Administration over a hundred times I
know how to litigate uh with him
one little problem for Alvin nothing to
brag about his only path of admission
into the Trump haters Hall of Fame is
through a sleazy lawyer and Stormy
Daniels
well today the grand jury got to hear
from a man who knew former Trump lawyer
Michael Cohen very well
his erstwhile advisor Robert Costello
who brief reporters after he spoke to
the grand jury today
well he blew the lid on D.A Bragg's star
Witness
there must be a hundred instances in
those documents of him lying to us and
during that first meeting this is
important he said we were there for two
hours at the Regency Hotel he said maybe
every three or four minutes he'd be
talking to us while pacing like a wild
tiger in a cage back and forth back and
forth and point at us and he'd say I
want you guys to know I will do whatever
the f it takes I will never spend one
day in jail he must have said that close
to 20 times you think a guy whose
mindset right at that moment is a lie
cheat steal shoot somebody whatever it
takes I'm not going to jail and that's
why I went in there today to tell these
people the truth about who the real
Michael Cohen is now I know Costello is
an ally of Donald Trump but he
volunteered to go into the grand jury
and was extremely convincing on the
issue of Cohen's credibility
listen if they want to go after Donald
Trump and they have solid evidence so be
it but Michael Cohn is far from solid
evidence this guy by any Prosecutor's
standard and I used to be Deputy Chief
of the Criminal Division in the southern
district of York I wouldn't have touched
a guy like Michael Cohen especially if
he's a convicted perjurer
so any prosecution of trump is simply
going to further erode The public's
faith and yet another American
institution District Attorneys now it's
not about upholding the rule of law it's
about pursuing a vendetta against the
one man who they know for sure will
reverse Biden's disastrous decisions on
everything from the border our dealings
with China the war in Ukraine oil and
gas that's just to name a few
the Press is dying to suck everyone into
these protracted debates about issues
that are very important yet not defining
In This Moment Of History
today it was what will Ron DeSantis do
or say on the potential Trump protests
will he condemn potential violence is
this another January 6 in the offing
now all these detours are distractions
and they keep the spotlight off Biden
for his role in bringing us to the brink
of both a domestic economic crisis and a
geopolitical crisis
when Joe Biden pledged to restore both
dignity and respect to U.S foreign
policy remember he did that during 20 uh
the 2016 campaign the 2020 campaign
he didn't mention he'd helped drive two
of our most dangerous adversaries into
each other's arms
China attaches great importance to the
china-russia relations we are each
other's biggest neighboring country
as well as strategic partners
and Putin clearly has a man crush on
President XI
I'm happy to congratulate you in person
on the re-election as head of the
Chinese State over the last years China
has made a huge leap forward in its
development in the whole world is of a
genuine interest and we're jealous a bit
now he should be jealous After All
American Elites dedicated globalists
they're directly responsible for making
China Rich which gave the CCP the money
to build its economy and expand its
military and its leverage around the
world
now our establishment is thrilled to use
Trump or any other distraction to
prevent its own supporters from
recognizing the Calamity facing the
United States under Democrat rule
over the past two plus years now America
has gotten weaker American families have
become poorer and America's ability to
influence events around the world is
collapsing
and the bite Administration seems
totally comfortable with the decline of
the United States
look our banking system is failing
inflation is out of control the FED is
incompetent and the Biden
administration's position on China and
Russia it makes no sense
think about this we consider Putin the
most evil man on earth right
then president XI we heard him today
considers Putin his great friend
and yet the White House keeps saying
that they want to work with President XI
on economic issues this is insane
we still want to get secretary blinken
back to Beijing and we're still hopeful
we can get that back on the counter as a
matter of fact we're having discussions
with the PRC right now about potential
visit by uh secretary Yellen and
secretary raimondo to go over there and
talk about economic issues yeah go visit
the people who have slaves in
concentration camps basically
but apparently the Biden team is so weak
that they can't even get people on the
phone it's been about a week since
President Biden said he was going to
speak to president XI soon is that
called been scheduled yet John
it hasn't been scheduled and he'll have
a call with President XI at the
appropriate time we'd like to make sure
that this bilateral relationship is
serving not only the best interests of
the American people uh but also the
world
I don't recall that President Trump ever
had trouble getting China on the phone
or any of his cabinet do you
now again the money we give to China
with our massive trade deficit is right
now being used to prop up the man who
President Biden claims should be
overthrown obviously I'm talking about
Putin
the Biden people confirmed in a new
report that Chinese ammo is being used
right now in Russia by Russia in Ukraine
doesn't that sound like lethal Aid to
you or does that not count
now this is why not a single government
on Earth takes the Biden Administration
seriously
I think that Putin and she fear press
them with
fear or they not it is not about fear
it's about President Biden advancing our
foreign policy goals around the world is
about President Biden revitalizing these
alliances and Partnerships
laughs
they really should have a laugh track at
these briefings that would make it much
more entertaining
now it should be clear to everyone that
the Biden White House is trying to run
out the clock here
at this point they all understand that
the economy is not going to improve that
Putin is probably going to win the war
in Ukraine and that XI oversees the most
powerful military in the world
so what's left for them is to try to do
everything to occupy national attention
with non-stop Trump drama or DeSantis
demonization or a combination of the two
or their old standby racial hatred
also you should prepare to see them
pressure the FED to slow or freeze
interest rates to avoid recession they
already started doing that
and that means inflation is here to stay
which Democrats think they can weather
more easily than a recession politically
I'm speaking
now three years ago during our summer of
riots it appeared that Democrats had
adopted a policy of rule or ruin in
other words they'd be Trump or they'd
ruin the country
but now in the third year of the Biden
Administration it's apparent they can do
both
Democrats can rule and ruin America
the real question for the next year
though is whether the American people
can begin to see through all of this
because if we are forced to suffer
through another four years of this
the consequences for America will be
catastrophic
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else